There's a whole set of expectations that
are governing what we're doing,
like you don't want me to take your your
little tablet there and smash it.
That would be shocking,
right?
You would know what the hell to do,
You'd be somewhere different if I did
that and you wouldn't know where you
were and that's another thing to know
because that's a fundamental difference.
There is a fundamental difference
between knowing where you are and not
knowing where you are.
I think it's in some sense the
fundamental difference.
You can think about it as the
distinction between explored an
unexplored territory,
but you have to.
I don't know if you've ever taken a cat
to a new house.
Cats hate that,
and because in their old house and maybe
in their old neighborhood,
they slunk around at the edges,
checking everything out.
They start out freight afraid.
They check everything out.
They know where to hide.
They know where to.
They knew,
they knew,
they know what safe and they know that
because they go somewhere and nothing
happens and so then the assuming that
it's safe and they slowly build up a
neighborhood that they're comfortable
with.
My Dad used to take the dog for a walk
and then the cat got lonesome and so it
started to follow him and first of all
it would just go along the buildings,
the houses on their route,
no hiding really from predators and
after awhile it got kinda comfortable
with that and then it would follow right
behind the dog,
but it had a border and if my dad took
the dog over one street too many for the
cat,
the cat would just sit on the corner and
you know,
cry like a cap cries.
It was like,
that's it for me,
man.
I'm not going any farther out into the
unknown.
And so the distinction between the
territory that you have mastered and the
territory that you haven't mastered is a
fundamental distinction.
It's the distinction between home and
the strange land.
And the thing about familiar territory
for people is that most of the familiar
territory that we inhabit is other
people because we're so social.
So you can't really think it's a weird
way of thinking about territory.
It's not exactly geographical objective
territory.
It's territory with a dominance
hierarchy in it and the dominance
hierarchy has a predictable structure
and you know where you fit in it most of
the time.
And so that when you act out in that
territory surrounded by Europe,
people then often you get what you want
and you're so thrilled about that
because you just don't want someone
acting radically around you.
Like,
and you know that.
So he walked down bloor and there's
people there that should really be
institutionalized.
But we did institutionalize them all so
they could be free and free to be,
you know,
suffering and malfunctioning out on the
street.
That's what the freedom ended up being.
But you know,
you'll walk by someone like that who's
moderating away to the voices in his
head,
didn't,
you know,
maybe
striking out against whatever it is
that's plaguing him.
And you will make eye contact.
You might even go across the street,
you're certainly going to give him a
wide berth.
You're going to keep a distance between
him and you and you're going to hope
that you don't attract his attention
because he's not in the dominance
hierarchy and you don't know what the
hell he might do and that's unexplored
territory too.
That's another way of thinking about it,
like we inhabit time and space,
not just space and not just time.
We inhabit time and space and our
territories are spacial.
Temporal.
We're here now and this is safe now and
it saved partly because of the physical
structure and it's working,
but it's also safe because none of you
are manifesting peculiar behavior,
but if you started to manifest peculiar
behavior,
if you stood up and started monitoring
or yelling or maybe attacking someone
next to you,
all the rest of you would freeze first
because then all of a sudden this would
be unexplored territory.
The match between what you want,
which is a peaceful lecture that you
hope has some content.
The match between what you want and
what's happening has vanished and so
then you're not.
You don't know where you are and so then
what do you do when you don't know where
you are?
What do you do when you don't know what
to do?
Well,
if you're your computer,
you just crash,
but
you know what good is that to you?
You're just going to die.
That isn't helpful.
You freeze first and then maybe you
cautiously,
cautiously attended,
or maybe you don't.
Maybe you just keep your damn eyes
averted and you sit there and you hope
that no one notices you.
That's a Predator or prey response,
right?
That's like a rabbit frozen when it
thinks a fox is looking at it and we
were prey animals for a long time.
There was a cat that they recently
discovered,
a prehistoric cat that had this bottom
single tooth and they found out that a
human skull fit right inside its mouth
and so it could grab you here and Pierce
the back of your skull with its with its
single tooth and that's what it was
evolved for.
So you know it's under such conditions.
We evolved and we're predators
obviously,
but were tasty predators and so other
things were perfectly happy to eat us.
And so when you're aware you don't know
what to do,
you act like a prey animal and that's
probably what you shouldn't do because
maybe if you keep your head down and
shut the hell up there,
be any attention to attracted to you and
maybe you'll get through it.
You know,
you,
you might decide unlikely to intervene
and take the guy down,
but,
but you would be the exception rather
than the norm.
And it's unsurprising.